can't get a good clap on Christ because
you're hearing maybe is it loud it's
pretty loud no I felt better I hurt my
bring still feels like it's not it's
your hearing you clap loud good morning
believe nation today's message is good
morning believe nation today's message
is don't ask for permission over to you
Ava Duvernay you know we have to work
without permission especially as women
in this industry who are we asking for
permission to do what we want to do that
should be eradicated you need to set a
path and start walking and that is what
I've tried to do and what I try to
encourage folks to do walk with me let
me walk with you let's walk with each
other I think you know so much of the
industry is very permission-based and
once you get out of your mind that you
have to ask anyone to do what you want
to do you'll be better for it so what do
you think I think that in our culture we
are very much permission-based even even
in school right may I go to the washroom
really sort of condition that anything
that you want to do for yourself you
need that permission slip and in life as
you get older you realize you sort of
still not mentality of the permission
slip but maybe some people learned
earlier some people learn later that you
don't need that you can pave your own
Road and that you can walk this path
even will in spite of the fact that
everyone you know your family might
think it's a bad idea and when we talk
about entrepreneurs it's taking a chance
taking opportunity right doing something
a little bit differently I mean you take
calculated risks are you still taking
risks and it's not always going to be
what the crowd thinks is right and you
know when you think of Amazon for
example selling books online right that
was like insane who would want to order
books online but like you paid your path
you see it you see something there you
work through it and you make you make
gold and you make gold yeah how you make
gold I like it I see this in two
different ways one is when it's just
related to you
and then one when it relates to others
as well when it's you I don't think you
should care as much about what other
people think you know I was dealing with
someone in the comments today's like
don't you care about how putting this
pushing up on your channel reflects on
you like I don't care I don't care what
you think of me like I'm putting out
value I'm doing this because I want to
do this and as I've grown older as an
entrepreneur I care less and less about
how people see me and what they think of
the stuff that I'm doing I know that the
intention is always pure my intention is
good and so I just learned more and more
to trust my instincts and what I want to
do I get an idea I just do it I don't
care if Alex likes it I don't care of
Jason likes it I don't care for anybody
else likes it I like it I want to do it
you don't want to join me I'll be an
army of one I'm going to put it out it's
happening that's my mentality and I've
just got more and more stubborn
interesting in my home police he's had
to deal with it so if this thing that
you want to do just go and do it you
don't need your friends permission or
your family's permission or anybody
else's permission just go and start
doing it and that's a big step for a lot
of people the other one is when it
relates to others and if you're doing
with clients or friends or relationships
you have to factor that in what's the
impact on them going to be as well right
is it this is going to hurt them is
going to harm them in some way and if it
has a potential negative impact then you
could still not ask for permission but
you better be right you know I will do
this to my clients a lot the brand the
brands that I work with they want to do
something that I just feel is not going
to work I feel like this is not going to
work you guys don't get it you don't
understand and instead of me fighting
with them I just don't tell them and I
just do it but I better be right right
because if they want me to do something
than I do the opposite and it doesn't
work out then that's pretty bad on me as
an example of my book I wanted it
formatted in a certain way my publisher
didn't like it from the start I want it
this way so I spent however long months
and months and months writing it in that
format to the point where now it's
really too late to go back and switch it
right so I box myself into this corner
because I felt it's the right thing to
do even though she didn't like it so
that's on me it better work right and
I'm confident that I will I like it I'm
a fan of it obvious i wouldn't have done
it so there's a risk i think it's when
something with me i'm always i'm willing
to take a lot more risk i'm okay with
failure happy with failure because i
learned from it but when involves other
people or you know clients or
relationships you got to add a little
bit more just awareness of how it's
going to impact their lives as well and
have that kind of certainty that it's
going to work out otherwise it's on you
you're going to be ready to deal with
the consequences so the question today
today is well as one personal story you
can share with us of where you took your
own path leave it in the comments below
and join the discussion thank you guys
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and i'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso